hola soy el señor anderson y en este
vídeo voy a hablar acerca del programa
el programa esencialmente está tomando
las características que son compartidas
por los organismos y después reúne una
hipótesis de cómo crees que pueden estar
relacionados o un árbol filogenético no
es un árbol filogenético es sólo una
suposición de cómo puede ocurrir
afortunadamente ayer me estaba
trabajando con un poco de agua estancada
y descubrir estas siete criaturas y les
he puesto mi nombre por supuesto la
especie es anders inning acuáticos y
todas son subespecies de están
básicamente tienen muchas
características diferentes y entonces
vamos a intentar poner las juntas en un
claro grama y bueno cuando estaban
creciendo seguramente vieron plaza
sésamo y solían jugar un juego llamado
una de estas cosas no es como la otra
entonces esa es una buena manera de
pensar en un plato grama cuál de estos
no se ve como los otros cuál de estos es
el grupo externo
ustedes deberían de ser capaces de
averiguarlo el primero sería ce y ahora
antes de que haga clic en el siguiente
traten de adivinar cuál sería el
siguiente en salir según esta idea bien
sería bien porque no tiene un ojo el
cual si tenemos en gm así que el
siguiente sería g traten de jugar cuál
sería el siguiente es correcto va a ser
de y después de ese am y después
efe y finalmente después tenemos a él
así que probablemente podrían hacer eso
solo colocarlos en orden observando qué
características tienen así que aquel que
esté en un grupo externo será que el que
no tenga ninguna de esas características
o tal vez una y entonces básicamente un
claro grama se va a aparecer a esto va a
ser una hipótesis de cómo estas cosas
llegaron a existir podríamos observar
aquí abajo y decir viene justo aquí hay
una característica llamada membrana
celular
en otras palabras todas ellas tienen una
membrana celular es decir todo lo que se
ramifican
a partir de este punto va a tener una
membrana celular y que es este punto de
ramificación bien puedes pensarlo como
un ancestro común de todos los
organismos que están aquí ahora a partir
de aquí podemos decir que la siguiente
característica sería su forma circular y
seguimos subiendo un poco cuál será la
siguiente característica que tienen
bueno la siguiente cosa va a ser el ojo
entonces podremos seguir todo el camino
hacia arriba y fijarnos en qué
características se agregan esas
características las usamos para hacer un
claro grama hay algunas cosas
interesantes que deberías saber así que
si observamos este claro grama y decimos
que es real quienes están más
relacionados está
efe más relacionado a él o está más
relacionado a esa es una pregunta
realmente buena y yo diría que la
respuesta correcta es la y esto debido a
que en un claro grama o en un árbol
filogenético el tiempo irá en esta
dirección así que vamos a escribirlo
en otras palabras este va a ser el
ancestro común más viejo y después vamos
a ir progresivamente hacia arriba
eso significa que f y m compartirán un
ancestro común justo aquí
efe am van a compartir un ancestro común
más hacia abajo justo aquí y ya que éste
está mucho más atrás en el tiempo
nosotros vamos a decir que f está más
relacionado a él pero este es un modelo
muy simplista y de nuevo es una
suposición de cómo podría ocurrir una
cuestión más difícil puede hacer que
agreguemos uno nuevo digamos que
descubrimos algo como esto
esta es la especie o subespecie en donde
ponemos a esta subespecie h en este
claro grama y bueno cuando hablo con los
estudiantes en clase ellos dicen que hay
tres o cuatro áreas donde podríamos
agregar a esta subespecie h así que
algunos estudiantes piensan que
deberíamos agregarla ramificando por
aquí y otros que deberíamos ramificar de
otros dicen que deberíamos ramificar
justo por aquí
y otros que deberíamos replicar algo
como esto entonces todas estas son
opciones posibles pero aunque todas
estas son hipótesis podemos poner muchas
más hipótesis por ahí ahora entre
comillas cuál sería la respuesta
correcta bien si tuviera que poner esto
en algún lugar lo que haría sería
ponerlo justo aquí porque si yo la
pusiera más atrás antes de que el ojo
evolucione es decir ya que no tenemos
este ojo en h podría haber ocurrido así
pero sería extraño que además
evolucionen exactamente los mismos
dientes y los mismos pinchos defensivos
cosa que encontramos más arriba entonces
una suposición más factible sería que
ramificará de esta app y después pierda
su ojo y como pudo perder su ojo bien si
tuviéramos que poner uno de estos en un
área donde no haya luz el ojo no
representaría una ventaja y entonces
muchas veces cuando estamos añadiendo
algo a un claro grama pensamos en sólo
añadir
características que son adicionales pero
sepan esto es tan probable perder una
característica como ganar una nueva por
lo tanto esta será una buena solución
para saber en dónde va a h y de lo que
estoy hablando ahora es de la navaja de
ockham en otras palabras estoy hablando
de la teoría de parsimonia qué significa
eso básicamente significa que si todas
las cosas son iguales la explicación más
simple de cómo ocurrió es probablemente
la más correcta en otras palabras si yo
salgo en la mañana y hay un vaso de
leche que se derramó en la cocina
entonces podrían aparecer un montón de
hipótesis sobre qué es lo que pasó
podrían ser extraterrestres podría ser
pie grande podría ser un terremoto
masivo o podría ser mi gato y si yo
tuviera que observar todas estas es más
probable que haya sido mi gato no
significa que sea correcto no significa
que los extraterrestres no bajaron y
derramaron mi leche sólo significa que
es más probable que el gato lo hizo
entonces cuando estás elaborando un
programa intentas hacer algo así y
tratas de usar esta idea de parsimonia
la idea de que la explicación más simple
es la mejor déjenme mostrarles un
ejemplo de esto este sería un claro
grama que se creó para primates y se
observamos de nuevo el anterior en
general en biología solíamos usar todas
estas características para colocar
organismos en un plato grama
características físicas pero puede
imaginarse que no es una gran manera de
clasificar la vida o incluso demostrar
las relaciones evolutivas ahora tenemos
el adn
tenemos la genética entonces tú puedes
crear un programa como éste solo
secuenciando el adn
en todos estos diferentes organismos y
después arrojando los resultados en una
computadora y así crear un programa
plausible y en donde están ustedes bueno
ustedes están justo aquí en el lado
humano y si tuviéramos que ir a través
desde la izquierda están los lémures y
los lori nos ellos comparten un ancestro
común
aquí pero también muestran un ancestro
común lejano con todos los primates aquí
en la posición inicial después vamos a
hablar de los terceros o los monos del
nuevo mundo y los monos del viejo mundo
estos son términos un poco raros el
mundo del nuevo mundo es un mono
sudamericano un ejemplo podría ser el
mono ardilla y el mono del viejo mundo
sería como un babuino así que todos
estos monos tienen cola y ahora
continuaremos con los simios el primero
sería el equipo que sería el primer
punto de ramificación después tenemos al
orangután el gorila el chimpancé y
podemos poner al bono bo ramificado
justo por aquí y finalmente tenemos a
los humanos entonces de nuevo esto es
solo un claro grama es una hipótesis de
cómo estas cosas están relacionadas y
estamos viendo a las características que
están compartidas por todos estos
miembros pero las grandes
características que estamos viendo ahora
son las estructuras homólogas de adn en
otras palabras en donde la genética
coincide
significa que tienen un ancestro en
común y eso significa que pasamos de
gorilas a humanos no sólo significa que
tenemos un ancestro al inicio de este
punto entonces estos fueron los claro
gramas espero que todo esto te haya sido
bastante útil